sorge zu eurem leben stellen sie sich
mal vor sie blättern durch die
adressbüchern und müssen gleich
reihenweise namen durchstreichen nahe
menschen dahingerafft opfer der aids
epidemie
so hat es der deutsche filmemacher rosa
von praunheim erlebt er dokumentierte
wie sehr diese krankheit gerade in der
kulturszene einschlug und welch kreative
kraft dieses leid wiederum hervorbrachte
[Musik]
man sprach davon dass es ein kino kost
war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
lang ist's her fast 30 jahre seit rosa
von praunheim schweigen gleich tod
gedreht hat eine dokumentation über die
new yorker kreativszene in einer zeit in
der aids ausbricht tötet und niemand
weiss warum
insofern waren viele leute sehr
verzweifelt und haben dann ihre wut raus
gelassen das therapeutisch auch gut war
das ist nicht passiv einfach nur privat
ertragen haben sondern eben auch
öffentlich gemacht habe auf die straße
gegangen sind haben sich angekettet an
pharmafirmen die halt überteuerte
medikamente angeboten haben und künstler
haben versucht auf ihre weise das
auszudrücken
noch ist es zeit etwas zu unternehmen
bleibt nicht stumm
die regierung hält 52.000 aids tote für
entbehrlich
rosa von praunheim trifft im big apple
erkrankte künstler wie den schweizer
maler peter kunz dessen bilder sind
metaphern für das erlebte für das leiden
einer ganzen künstler generation ist
dann sah ich mir die zeichnungen an und
es sind sehr traurige engel die ich
gemalt habe
junge boten die eine besondere schwere
an sich haben keith haring selbst
hiv-positiv malt seine erinnerungen an
angstfreie tage an die wand ein erinnern
an freiheit und leichtigkeit die kunst
jener zeit will aufmerksamkeit für eine
epidemie generieren die von politik und
öffentlichkeit ignoriert wird und
radikal und wütend wie der dichter und
künstler dann moffett nicht werden dazu
über sterben und ich will das erlebnis
meines todes licht für einer ruhigen und
höflich angelegenheit werden lassen
ich werde meine sexualität feiern mit
dem spielfilm ein virus kennt keine
moral gehört rosa von praunheim zu den
pionieren der aids prävention
er spielt den vorsichtigen in einem
schwulen kosmos wo niemand zu wissen
scheinen wie gefährlich das virus ist
damit stößt er auf ablehnung gerade bei
den homosexuellen
wenn man dann in einer stadt cham und da
waren wunderhübsche jungs die da im
publikum waren die sich totlachen wie
blöd safer sex du kommst du ja ein paar
jahre später und die hälfte von denen
wörter nicht mehr da das jahr 1995
bringt die zentrale zäsur in der
geschichte von aids innerhalb weniger
monate gelingen die entscheidenden
fortschritte in der hiv forschung aus
einer todbringenden epidemie wird eine
behandelbare chronische erkrankung die
medizin habe zwar für den
paradigmenwechsel gesorgt sagt
kulturwissenschaftlerin beate schabbach
aber erst mit der kunst gelingt auch die
kommunikation
da hat glaube dass keiner leisten wo zum
beispiel stehen vor der medizin einfach
kommunikativen erleichtert dass ich ganz
klar
es geht nicht mehr um proteste und
prävention sondern um aufarbeitung um
reflexion die us amerikanische
fotografin nan goldin verkleinert mit
ihren bildern die distanz zu den
erkrankten weil sie nicht nur vom
sterben sondern auch von nähe und alltag
erzählt
[Musik]
in dem moment so zeige hattler kunst
möglichkeit der reform vor ein paar die
auslöser sechs autobiografisch oder
durch figuren vorüber betroffen sind vor
hiv wo eigentlich der wert vor der
empathie oder die verbindung von
menschen über empathie probiert
schließen
da brauchen wir am ende kunst der
rhetorik der biografie der geschichte
solche ikonen fotografiert wolfgang
tillmans in den 1990 er jahren
er porträtiert die rave und
schwulenszene londons
der fotograf verliert viele freunde und
seinen lebensgefährten die erkrankung
scheint in seinen arbeiten nur noch als
zitat auf den eigenen hiv status
kommentiert er mit einem bild
medikamente mit seinem namens etikett
der aid aktivismus von einst weit weg
heute erzählt die kunst von einem virus
der zwar nicht mehr tötet im leben aber
immer noch fesseln anlegen kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die routine tv